or coming to you this Thursday
unfortunately from a very sick city a
place where many of the people in charge
aren't just wrong but increasingly are
irrational Washington is in the grip of
unprecedented mass hysteria over Russia
yes Russia take three steps back it's a
freezing poor country on the other side
of the globe where the average life
expectancy is lower than that in
Bangladesh Russia is a place whose
economy is smaller than the economy of
Texas it's a country that can barely
produce a working escalator or
non-poisonous vodka and yet that country
which was guarded by sober people as sad
and increasingly irrelevant is according
to Democrats in Washington in virtually
complete control of the workings of the
US government they tell us that every
day and they're starting to seem like
they believe it that's demented the most
striking new example comes from former
Director of National Intelligence Jim
clapper in an interview just yesterday
clapper claimed that Russia flipped the
results of the 2016 election got Trump
elected over Hillary asked for evidence
of that clip clapper admitted he didn't
have any because of course he doesn't
have any nobody else has any either
there is no evidence that any foreign
country changed a single American vote
in 2016 and by the way that was clappers
position just two years ago when it was
the position of the Obama administration
that vote tampering by a foreign power
was completely irresponsible and
impossible to contemplate now that Trump
is an office of course clapper and other
Democrats are warning that Russia will
try to subvert this year's midterms as
well they have no evidence for that
either now keep in mind that Jim clapper
is not some fringe radio show host or
back-bencher in Congress for years he
held one of the top intelligence posts
in the country yet he's delusional
that's terrifying and he's not the only
delusional one the CIA operatives spying
on the Trump campaign also sounds like
he's unbalanced reports today from the
Daily Caller finds that that man once
falsely accused a Russian academic at
Cambridge University of being a Russian
infiltrator and said an entire
intelligence seminar was compromised by
Russian agents like Kim Philby were
still alive this afternoon congressional
leaders received a classified briefing
from DOJ and Intel officials about
action
all spying that took place in 2016 not
spying from spooky Russian agents and
from the Kremlin but from the Obama FBI
and that might put some of this in
perspective tom Fitton is the president
of judicial watch Molly Hemingway is an
editor at The Federalist they join us
now thank you to you both my I'll start
with you and I hate to start an
immediate question but it determines how
people understand the story what they
read and what they see on television
they're still news outlets as of tonight
that are pretending like there was no
spying on the Trump campaign so can you
just say definitively do we know as a
factual matter that the Obama FBI spied
in the Trump campaign or don't we well
everyone knows that there was a spy and
in fact people who were involved in the
spying are admitting that there's a spy
they're saying though that because the
government term is human intelligence
informant or something like that that
therefore it's not a spy whereas normal
Americans understand that when you are
gathering information on someone
surreptitiously that's the common
definition of spying and more than that
that's just a stunning revelation that
this was happening under the previous
administration that there would be this
kind of surveillance not just at least
one human intelligence informant but
also wiretaps National Security Letters
which are how you can secretly get a
subpoena and who knows who knows what
else is going on so actually like
widespread spying involving multiple
people in the Trump campaign and we
still don't really know what's going on
because they're trying to fight that's
the point and by the way I should point
out in the interest of honesty that
these are agencies controlled by the the
Trump White House so it's not clear to
me at all why we don't know this and
that why the committees in the Congress
who have oversight over all of this
don't know there was a meeting today
famously about this Tom do you think
members of Congress again charged with
oversight of this stuff know the answer
as of tonight no my understanding is
they're still being strung along this
meeting was for show we want to see the
documents so why would they be strung
along because these agencies have
contempt for congressional oversight you
have this extraordinary situation of a
republican-controlled Justice Department
and FBI attacking and undermining the
congressional oversight activities of a
republican-controlled House and Senate
and they didn't want to turn over the
documents so I said well have a meeting
and we'll talk about the secret spy game
we had but it won't be public we won't
tell you what we have
in terms of turning over documents which
is still the big fight you know Judicial
Watch specializes isn't a Freedom of
Information Act because we recognize the
government documents really tell you
what went on and government official
descriptions of what went on as we're
learning from the Obama gang that's
describing this spy as an informant in a
dishonest way we need to see the
documents we need to know how much money
was this person paid was money was money
transferred as a result of his
involvement with the Trump campaign
who else was he working look or there
were there others but there's a time
limit there's a timer sand is passing
through the hourglass here if Democrats
take the house and take control majority
control of these committees then how
will we find out they have no interest
in information this is why it would be
nice if everyone on both sides of the
aisle had a common understanding that's
spying on political opponents is not a
good precedent and it's not good for
having Americans having confidence in
the CIA liberals say that I I mean there
been a few I think very exceedingly few
Mark Penn is someone who was a Clinton
adviser who has been making that
argument in addition to the issue that
the Department of Justice thinks that
they are accountable to no one not the
president under who's in whose branch
they serve or Congress which funds them
and created them I think it also must
mean that the information is really
damaging really dangerous that they're
willing to subvert any authority in
order to keep that a secret so this is
something that I think they think they
can keep this from getting out I don't
think they will actually yeah in the
pretexts they used to hide this
information from public view are
dishonest so tonight Eric Felten report
Washington has a piece explaining that
one of the many facts redacted by the
FBI in documents obtained through FOIA
reveals that Annie McCabe spent seventy
thousand dollars on a piece of office
furniture they held that back on grounds
of national security
does that imperil us Tom as a country
now that our enemies know that Andy
McCabe spent seventy thousand dollars on
a piece of office furniture I mean of
course it doesn't and it shows you that
the FBI and Department of Justice can't
be trusted to evaluate fairly whether
documents should be released or not
and the president who constitutionally
runs the agencies needs to intervene and
stopping at let and and stop himself
from being strung along
by the his appointees and tell them to
release these records let's review the
weekly never listen to your lawyers if
there's one piece of advice I have for
my children it's don't listen to your
lawyers because they don't have the
truth apart hey take their rights out to
account and get the information out just
do the right thing I would say thank you
both very much great to see you